the reason why a lot of country artists
don't really speak on a lot of matters
it's out of fear that they're going to
be
cancelled out of this format and that's
the way they make their money that's the
way they take care of their families
and for me it was like i've already hit
rock bottom i can't go any lower i'm
just going to speak my truth
well that truth earned mickey guyton her
first ever grammy nomination for her
deeply personal song
black like me making mickey the first
black female solo artist
ever to earn an odd in a country music
time you category her up just so the
world could let her down
and last september the texas native
continued to make history
when she became the first black female
artist to perform her song
at the academy of country music awards i
didn't understand the gravity until
after
the performance and it's it is heavy
because
you're celebrating but you know there's
still so much inequality
so it's amazing as that moment is and i
appreciate it and i receive it like we
still have a lot of work to do
also making history last year kane brown
who became the first black male solo
country artist to cross
genres and perform at the 2020 bet
awards
but it's not the first time the biracial
singer has broken barriers
in 2017 the release of his debut album
made kane the best-selling new country
artist in three years
and also the first artist to top all
five country music charts at the same
time
before you wouldn't see very many
country artists who aesthetically
you know look like you yeah is it nice
to kind of be in that mix and kind of
changing the face of what that genre
looks like
i think it's awesome just because i'm
different you know it takes a lot of
people
some time to you know get used to it
it's like but once they get used to it
it starts to grow and
i feel like it's it's honestly helped me
a lot just being different
and in 2018 fellow singer jimmy allen
made his mark on the industry
with his debut single best shot i'll
give you
my fish becoming the first black artist
to launch a career with the number one
single on country radio
when i found out what number one you
know kind of fell to my knees and you
know thank god and
teared up a little bit and then
something else hit me like all right
how can i change this narrative you know
how can i
make this a normal thing to where in two
to three years from now
being black isn't a thing you know what
i mean because in every other genre
it's not a thing representation is
important as far as when you see when
you're chasing a career no matter what
your career is
to be able to look at it and see someone
that looks like you
and honestly you know in the u.s as a
young kid we were told you could be
president you could be president
but until obama became president of the
u.s it was hard for a black kid to see
that
but i think the mindset should be
shifted to where
if you don't see representation you step
out and you become
that representation and that's exactly
what canadian country singer tay bay
hoped to do with this recent video
shotgun
[Music]
black you rider and my wife is caucasian
so i don't see why
you can't express that in music videos
just because it's country music doesn't
mean you can't have an interracial
couple i think country music has come a
long way in the last
five six years you know some of the
biggest superstars they have like kane
brown
darius rucker these are african-american
people so country music is turning a
corner
and being accepting of everybody and i'm
glad we were able to showcase that in
the music video